NIGHT.
SEE IS YOU HERE.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN SUBMITTED HER
RESIGNATION OVER THE WEEKEND.
SHE SEEMED LIKE A NICE PERSON.
SHE WAS ON THIS SHOW LAST WEEK
BUT IT'S POSSIBLE SHE WAS NEVER
A GOOD FIT FOR THE JOB SHE HAD.
DEPORTATIONS WERE LOWER THAN
UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
THE BORDER WENT FROM TROUBLED TO
OUT OF CONTROL.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 100,000
ILLEGALS SHOWING UP FROM MEXICO
EVERY MONTHS.
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN DID NOT CAUSE
THESE PROBLEMS.
SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN OPEN
BORDERS.
SHE BELIEVED IN THE LAW.
BUT THAT WAS TOO MUCH FOR THE
LEFT.
SHE WAS CHASED OUT OF
RESTAURANTS.
TODAY AS SHE LEFT THE WHITE
HOUSE THE MORONS ON TV MADE HER
YOUNG LIKE DR. MENTIONALA.
>> THAT'S THE WOMAN -- WHO PUT
CHILDREN IN CAGES AND BROKE UP
FAMILIES ACROSS THE BORDER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WILL BE RIGHT.
>> SHE SOLD HER SOUL.
SHE BECAME THE FACE OF
SEPARATING BABIES FROM HER
PARENTS.
>> NIELSEN WILL BE KNOWN FOR
IMPLEMENTING A CRUEL POLICY.
>> Tucker: FOR THE YEAR AND A
HALF SHE RAN THE HOMELAND
SECURITY DEPARTMENT, KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN SHOULD NEVER SLEEP
SOUNDLY AGAIN.
HOURS AFTER HER RESIGNATION, A
BLOOMBERG REPORTER TWEETED THIS.
NIELSEN'S NEXT STOP WILL BE
CAREFULLY WATCHED.
EXPECT TO SEE MAJOR OUT CRY FROM
IMMIGRATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUPS AND BEYOND."
SO KIRSTJEN NIELSEN SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO HAVE A JOB.
SHE MUST BE CAREFULLY WATCHED.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO WORK OR POST ON
SOCIAL MEDIA OR SELL BOOKS ON
AMAZON OR USE BANKS.
THAT'S THEIR POSITION.
IT'S THE DEFINITION OF
EXTREMISM.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH ME
MUST BE HURT.
THIS IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
DEEP DOWN EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
WE CAN'T KEEP LIVING LIKE THIS
WITH A SMALL GROUP OF UNHAPPY
ANGRY PEOPLE IN POWER TERRIFYING
THE REST OF US.
IT'S TOO STUPID AND CRUEL AND
DISHONEST.
COUNTRIES HAVE BORDERS.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE COUNTRIES.
SAYING THAT IS NOT HATE SPEECH.
IT'S TRUE.
BARACK OBAMA MUST NOT BE ON
TWITTER.
WHATEVER HIS MANY FAULTS, LISTEN
TO WHAT OBAMA SAID DURING HIS
SPEECH IN BERLIN.
>> I WORRY SOMETIMES WHEN, AS WE
THINK ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUE, WE THINK THAT
ANY MOVES TO ASSIMILATION OF THE
NEWNEWCOMERS TO THE EXIST
CULTURE IS A BETRAYAL.
SHOULD WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO
LEARN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
COUNTRY THEY ARE MOVING TOO?
OF COURSE.
DOES THAT MEAN THEY CAN NEVER
USE THEIR OWN LANGUAGE?
OF COURSE IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
IT'S NOT RACIST TO SAY IF YOU
ARE GOING TO BE HERE, YOU SHOULD
LEARN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
COUNTRY YOU JUST ARRIVED AT.
>> Tucker: ASSIMILATION IS
ESSENTIAL TO COHESION.
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD LEARN THE
LANGUAGE.
NOBODY DOUBTED THAT LEAST OF ALL
THE MILLIONS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARRIVED HERE AND LEARNED TO SING
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM IN ENGLISH.
ONLY UNDER THE REIN OF THE
MODERN LEFT IS IT FORBIDDEN TO
SAY WHAT IS TRUE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
THE TRUTH HASN'T CHANGED.
HYSTERIA DOESN'T MAKE FACTS
DISAPPEAR.
IMMIGRATION CAN BE A GREAT THING
FOR A COUNTRY, BUT IT MUST BE
CAREFULLY MANAGED.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE THE POPULATION
OF A COUNTRY IN 50 YEARS AND
ASSUME THINGS WILL GET BETTER.
EVEN BERNIE SANDERS UNDERSTANDS
IT.
BERNIE SANDERS IS AN
OLD-FASHIONED LEFTIST AND WANTS
MORE WELFARE BENEFITS.
THAT WON'T WORK WITH OPEN
BORDERS.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE WITH OPEN
SANDERS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE
OTHER DAY.
>> IF YOU OPEN THE BORDERS,
THERE IS A LOT OF POVERTY IN
THIS WORLD.
YOU WILL HAVE PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WE CAN DO.
WE CAN'T DO IT.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A LOT OF
POVERTY IN THIS WORLD BERNIE
SANDERS ACKNOWLEDGES.
THE POOR WILL MOVE HERE AND WE
WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR IT.
SANDERS MUST BE RACIST TO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
MAYBE HE JUST CARES ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO AMERICA.
ALL OF OUR LEADERS SHOULD CARE
WHAT HAPPENS TO AMERICA.
WE DON'T ELECT THEM TO IMPROVE
MEXICO, CHINA OR EUROPE.
WE PUT THEM IN OFFICE TO LOOK
OUT FOR THIS COUNTRY AND US.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT YOUR
PARENTS IF THEY TREATED YOU LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS WANTS TO TREAT THE
UNITED STATES?
KEEP THE DOORS UNLOCKED.
SLEEP IN YOUR BED AND EAT YOUR
BREAKFAST.
NOBODY KEEPING TRACK OF WHO THEY
ARE.
YOUR PARENTS ARE OVER AT THE
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE BRAGGING ABOUT
WHAT GOOD BEAM THEY ARE.
THAT'S WHAT NEGLECT LOOKS LIKE.
-- PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT IS HAPPENING.
PEOPLE KNOW IT.
LOOK AT THE POLLS.
AMERICANS WOULD LIKE TO SEE LESS
IMMIGRATION.
NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE BAD PEOPLE.
THEY WANT THE IMMIGRANTS WE TAKE
TO BE SKILLED ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND CONTRIBUTE TO
AMERICAN RIGHT AWAY AND NOT
THREE GENERATIONS FROM NOW.